ESPN senior fantasy analyst host of the
fantasy show which is gonna be ESPN
Fantasy Football Focus football podcast
tonight at the El Rey theater here in
Los Angeles California bringing him to
the Rich Eisen show in person Matthew
berry good to see you sir hello my
friend do you have any thoughts on this
it's the fugitive it's not close
it's the fugitive it's not close and
they set the is that what the pole is
currently yeah shot cause 61% right not
even Blade Runner 60 I'm not a I get the
you know I get the whole Blade Runner
thing if but the question specifically
is best non franchise Harrison Ford
movie yes sir I don't consider Blade
Runner is like its own movie like I
don't consider it to be a Harrison Ford
movie if that makes any sense
you mean like cuz like anyway look I
don't want to argue because I love the
fugitive and it's it's a Rio drop but
Tommy Lee Jones exact you could say
makes the fugitive that's not a Harrison
Ford film in a way well to bring up
Tommy Lee Jones yes but for me anyway
the question was asked to me best
Harris's non-french I'm going fugitive
remarkably that if you remove the
franchise's from his IMDB he's real MOG
Rafi it's kind of slim pickins when it
comes down to it a little bit but I love
Harrison Ford oh my god and by the way
you're removing his French I mean that's
like I mean moving his franchise so
you're talking about Indiana Jones it's
I mean you know it's a little bit of
like saying like you know if if you
remove the Jets from Joe Namath his
career was it's bad if you take the
magic away take Kareem abdul-jabbar from
away from the Lakers like his career
wasn't really terrific I know take the
touchdowns away from Tom Brady and what
do you go it's a little bit like that I
mean Indiana Jones and Star Wars I mean
you know I don't even count the Jack
Ryan stuff and whatever so Harrison Ford
is Harrison Ford's awesome good to have
you here Matthew berry the fantasy show
which made its debut just a few days ago
I guess on ESPN Plus that's right we're
hosting that you're here with the ESPN
Fantasy Football Focus football part of
me the ESPN fantasy focused football
podcast
yeah not easy to say no live on Twitter
this year okay we're live on Twitter so
you know this because you're
you're alive everyday but it's me this
was the first time you know we do the
Sunday show but this is the first time
that I'm I'm lot we do the podcast every
single day and I get a little salty on
the podcast so it's been a yeah it's
been a you know and listen and Twitter's
a minefield these days so you got to be
about it so we broadcast it live every
day on on Twitter so if you follow at
fantasy focus you can watch us at 11:00
Eastern gem you got it and we'll talk a
little bit more about that but let's
start diving into what people should
think do etc.etc
Sammy Watkins just moments ago was
removed from the practice field with
what was called home and let me get
right here according to Ted Cruz who's
the VP of communications the Chiefs yep
he hurt his hip a little bit so they
pulled him out and then we find out Nick
Foles who's probably not gonna start
anyway has an upper body soreness right
which could be anything
so what every day of my life and that
Tonio Brown gets sent home for just a
little something right here and we're
not gonna see Doug Baldwin because right
Auctions yeah how do you handle all of
this injury news when it's not so
obvious for your [ __ ] Allah different
ways first off very lucky on the podcast
on the on the fantasy shows to find you
Bell who's our injury analyst she does a
great job she works harder than anyone
at ESPN so mostly what I do is I just
ask to find you nice and but I will say
that it's sort of a case-by-case basis
so Sammy Watkins who has a long injury
history makes you a little nervous to
your point about Nick Foles you know is
he gonna start even if even if Wentz
misses the first game or something like
that chances are you're not starting
Nick Foles in your league like you you
could go to the waiver wire and get
another quarterback so you're not really
worried about that one Antonio Brown
doesn't really miss games not really
worried about Antonio Brown Doug Baldwin
it's the one that's the most curious to
me like that makes you a little nervous
because especially because baldwin is
somebody who i love coming to this year
175 targets I believe between Jimmy
Graham and Paul Richardson left the team
you know and we'll see if Brandon
Marshall has anything left you know
Doron Brown is you know but honestly
like I felt like Doug Baldwin is coming
into the best fantasy situation of his
career a guy who has more touchdowns
over the last three years than any wide
receiver other than Antonio Brown just a
great wide receiver is always under
you'd in fantasy and then now this new
thing but listen you know Pete Carroll
now candidly Pete Carroll's always
optimistic you know I mean very he's
very optimistic take what Pete says with
a grain of salt
but seems to be okay on Doug Baldwin I
think it lowers him a little bit but you
know there has never been major injury
history with with Baldwin Matthew berry
here on the Rich Eisen show again check
out ESPN plus the fantasy show and then
every single throughout the 2018 season
long streamed live on Twitter at 11:00
a.m. Eastern Time check out the ESPN
fantasy focus football podcast right
here on the Rich Eisen show but rich
this is another reason why you hold your
draft yes as close to the opening days
you can some of these animals hold their
draft and their animals they truly are
they hold their draft like the first
week of August I get emails from some
people like hey when are your rankings
me updated we're you know we're drafting
this weekend I'm like it's July dude
what are you doing like animals green
yeah what I it's it's very upsetting to
me what's the earliest you've ever heard
of a draft be mention oh I've heard
there are I know of leagues where they
draft right after the NFL Draft like so
they'll do like it's a dynasty and and
that kind of right it's right there
there they're just they're animals
they're they're anarchists it's its sons
Olivos anarchy yeah it's it's crazy why
would they do that though I don't know
and then they have to hold to what what
this right there's the argument there is
that they enjoy it they enjoy the
unknown that it makes a little bit more
you know competitive or fun or that kind
of stuff because everyone's sort of a
little bit blind at that point where you
just so many position battles haven't
been drawn I don't I personally don't
like so what's the best revenge story
that you've heard of late if somebody
who lost and had to do X Y & Z or
somebody who won you know right so we
did a bunch of those in in fantasy life
I've heard I've heard a bunch of good
ones let me see what I can tell on the
air like so there's a couple well so one
that I heard that I don't think I've
told which I just absolutely loved they
sent me a video of it so you know like
in grade school they have like those
8-foot hoops yeah right so basically
what it is the guy that lost the league
had to go and
stand under that 8-foot hoop and the
wrestle League just dunked on him they
all turn and they filmed it and they
shot it in slow motion
they added music to it and they put it
up on YouTube and so like the poor the
poor guy just had to get posterized by
everyone in his league you know so that
was pretty good I heard another one
where there it's an auction League yes
and so they get a they get a thousand
dollars of fake money for the auction
but the the two last place losers in
their league only get $500 and in order
to earn the other $500 to come to the
auction they had to go out and be mimes
on a street corner and with a hat and so
they could keep what up to $500 they
could keep whatever they earned as a
mime for their for their auction ground
and both guys ended up making $500 like
it took them all day but both guys ended
up like they had a sign explaining that
they've lost a pan until they get to
keep the 500 cash and then they get the
500 extra for the auction yeah I guess
so Wow yes can I tell you one where I
was on that business sure yeah yeah yeah
since I know that a lot of my poker
buddies are out there listening and
watching when would be upset if I did
not mention the one that I was
unfortunately on the wrong end of sure
cuz you know I what I do for a living
everybody loves giving me grief when
fantasy football does not go my way with
rice you know it's the vagaries are the
fantasy God's right Matthew there but
for the grace of any you go I mean you
must get that I playing a phantom first
sure of course I mean I played a fantasy
football league with Adam Schefter I
Adam Schefter
who to me is as plugged in as any human
on the universe literally I have sat
next to him every Sunday for eight years
I see all the coaches and assistant
coaches and GM's and people around the
league that text him constantly he knows
everything and yet he has never won the
league that we have played it I mean
he's he's he's as knowledgeable as there
is about the NFL about the inner
workings out who's getting started who's
not so yes the fantasy football gods
level the playing field right for
everybody I'm trying to express explain
that to everybody but it doesn't it is
an oblong ball made of leather weird
stuff happened - my favorite story I'm
told this one before
I'll tell you very quickly which will
take you up the hook so I told you how I
got on the hook but all right so go
ahead but this in terms of the vagaries
of fantasy football yes sir
okay as you know I work with Tim and
Matt Hasselbeck / - yes right so so so
Matt plays fantasy football and when he
was the quarterback of the seattle
seahawks 2009 he drafted as his fantasy
football quarterback that year himself
and his former Green Bay Packer teammate
Brett Favre memory used to Brett I used
to back up Brett yes so those were his
two quarterbacks and that was the year
that Brett his first year in Minnesota
so for your listeners I remember he was
awesome Brett Favre was awesome fantasy
quarterback in Minnesota so in week 5 of
the 2009 season Matt had a decision
Brett was playing the Rams who that year
were a really poor team and the Seahawks
were playing the Jags Jack's middle one
to straight Matt had missed two games
with a lower back injury and so Matt
Hasselbeck decided to bench himself and
start Brett Favre
I will save you guys the trouble of
looking this up what happens is the rams
get the vikings get a big Peterson has a
big day Brett Favre throws one
interception one touchdown finishes like
as something like the 18th best
quarterback in fantasy that year that
week meanwhile Matt Hasselbeck gets into
shootout with the Jags throws four
touchdown passes he's the number one
quarterback in fantasy sitting on his
own bench rich I want you to think about
this Matt Hasselbeck knew the tape had
seen the tape knew the gameplan knew the
matchups right could call an audible any
play literally touch the football on
every offensive play Matt Hasselbeck had
as much control over an NFL game as any
fantasy player ever in the history this
board and still got it wrong so if Matt
Hasselbeck can't get it right what hope
do any of us have correct
I feel off the hook now life
unfortunately though I told two guys in
the league who were I was going against
when I was up by a game with a couple of
games to go in the season they're like
let's make a bet who lasts longer okay
Ike in the playoffs and I'm like done
right John I was so confident
the bet was taking them the dinner or
vice versa right okay but it was also
dinner for ten huh okay wasn't just
taking them to dinner okay for ten
dinner for ten so I lost of course
don't know any of the details but I was
on the hook for dinner for ten they
chose a place called Mateos here in Los
Angeles
where you stare at a meatball and it
cost 50 bucks all right and one of the
guys that they chose to fill out the
table the rest of the league essentially
who was there in Los Angeles one of the
guys who I lost the bet to who was such
a big fan he's at Packers camp right now
watching his Packers cuz he's from
Wisconsin Murph
who's called in to the show starts
ordering like nineteen carpaccio's and
even worse even worse towards the end of
the meal ordering like this millionth
bottle of sparkling water instead of
taking you know like take her just so
upset I'm thinking this is gonna be
thousands of dollars bill comes and one
of the guys told told the staff to put
on a fake twenty five hundred dollar
bottle of wine and I fell for it hook
line and sinker and told him all off Wow
right cuz I had a little at me and I was
Oberon and I told him all off and they
put it on video and then let me know
that that was a fake bottle and it was
awful
by the way Hasselbeck beat the Jags 41
nothing 241 yards four touchdowns that
week right there you go and you work
with Matt and Tim and by the way I don't
know if you know I work with the lost
Hasselbeck yes force Brockman over there
who is actually you helix you once made
sage steel legitimately it opposed us we
party think you were a lost dude said
still she was mad that she had never met
me sooner than that night and but dinner
Matt great and Matt tells that story on
himself all the time and I've written
about it but that's my favorite fantasy
football story of all time I want to
take a quick break and give folks some
hardcore information that they could
actually use portably into a draft that
we're assuming they're not
that's actually still looking right good
I'm Matthew berry here again the fantasy
show with Matthew berry on ESPN plus the
ESPN Fantasy focused football podcast is
gonna be a live version at the El Rey
theatre here tonight in Los Angeles if
in your area go show up with field gates
in Stefania Bell or currently a Chargers
camp while you do the yeoman's work here
in the rich Johnson yeah I'm the one
selling the soap you got it we're back
with Matthew berry in a moment all right
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show the
2018 PGA Championship begins this week
and you can catch all the action at this
year's PGA Championship on Direct TV
Channel seven oh one through 705
starting on August 9th for channels of
coverage throughout the tournament plus
a mosaic Channel interactive features
in-depth player stats with enhanced
scorecards interactive leaderboard call
one eight hundred DirecTV to order
DirecTV because this is all compliments
of DIRECTV
Matthew berry here for another segment
as he's in Los Angeles to have a live
version of his fantasy football podcast
from the worldwide leader in sports on
ESP n-- plus is we can catch the fantasy
show Matthew berry is the host of that
and it made its debut just a couple of
days ago all right Matthew why should
they want me to mention fantasy football
marathon coming up cuz I know we're
gonna when is that start August 13th 6
p.m. ESPN espn2 twenty nine straight
hours of fan are you really on following
a monster yeah so I've done it for two
straight years I'm doing 230 or me and
shefter do it we're on the whole time
and then you you know Louis Riddick and
and all of our all of our insiders and
Enfield Yates fine balance in-house
about all of our fantasy experts Mike
Leigh and so all 13th August 13 in
straight hours yeah yeah that's amazing
a lot of energy drinks so let's just
quick one quick macro question for ya
what is your philosophy on drafting a
quarterback wait whenever like Aaron
Rodgers is gonna be sitting out there
for somebody is this round and
somebody's always taken that I I won't
consider a quarterback until the fifth
round that was a fifth round I know
honestly snake trap the center in a 10
team state craft okay which is ESPN
standard but even in a 12 team like the
quarterback position is so deep so we
did this study and we looked at average
drop position on espn.com and the
millions of people that play with us and
then we looked at where they finished in
terms of fantasy points
and over the last five years 52% of
quarterbacks that were drafted as top
ten quarterbacks
finished inside the top ten as a
quarterback so in other words basically
half of the quarterbacks that were
drafted as topical quarterbacks ended up
finishing the year as a top ten
quarterback it's just a it's a position
that it's so deep when you think about
guys like - Shaun Watson or Carson Wentz
from last year
here are some guy here's some guys that
are going outside the top ten
hmm so an ESPN where you play one one
quarterback and so in theory the top ten
quarterbacks are your starters right yep
some of the quarterbacks going outside
the top ten right now Jimmy Garoppolo
Alex Smith Matt Ryan Philip Rivers
Matthew Stafford I mean like it's great
quarterbacks that you would be perfectly
fine with having as your starter so you
know I mean like Andrew Luck's going
around ten like so it's just really
would you have would you you'd go there
Andrew Luck at ten sure I mean first off
he's throwing real footballs which is
exciting I mean like like let's be clear
here no more nerfs for Andrew Luck
no look Andrew Luck went healthy the
last two years he was fully healthy was
a top four fantasy quarterback so you're
telling me I got a potential top four
fantasy quarterback at QB 10 and if he
if it does not work out for Andrew Luck
for whatever reason the pool is so deep
something we even talked about guys like
like mahomes or tribe it's key rivers
goes late every year like I said I
mentioned I love Alex Smith I'm not
crazy about dak Prescott but he's going
outside the top ten this year there's
Brady I Brady - - yeah I've Rodgers one
Brady - it doesn't concern you know
Edelman first four weeks doesn't concern
you I know look I understand what I'm
saying into a microphone on planet Earth
for people to listen to in here right
Brady I have nothing but man love for
sure okay the goat but 40 by Q you're
you're gonna sit there for a fantasy
draft and roll the dice at age 41 he's
gonna do stuff that nobody's ever done I
understand that he's done stuff that
nobody's ever done before Eddie at 40
right age 30 I mean like look um yeah
okay I mean like if you're asking me
do I doubt Tom Brady no I do not doubt
Tom Brady do I doubt Bill Belichick do I
doubt that system josh mcdaniels no I
don't they'll put up numbers like I okay
Tom Brady is you know Tom versus time
Tom's winning it's Travis I mean just
like look at the scoreboard Tom's
winning I again I probably won't have
Tom Brady and in my teams this year
because I'm going to wait on a
quarterback I want to be one of the last
guys or last people in my draft to draft
a quarterback but yeah at a certain
point if Brady sitting there in the
fifth round
I'll take Tom Brady yeah I got no
concerns about Tom Brady I'm not worried
about age 41 I'm not worried about
missing Edelman he missed elemental last
year then just fine Matthew berry a
couple more minutes here with him on the
Rich Eisen show those who have the first
overall selection what do you what do
you suggest I have labia unbell just
slightly over Todd Gurley but I think if
you go lay beyond Gurley
David Johnson Ezekiel Elliott Antonio
Brown any one of those five five you
take it one I've got no issue with
they're all superstars but at that level
you have to nitpick a little bit and lay
beyond bell for me has done it longer
more consistent contract year for him I
my sense is that the Steelers gonna move
on from lay beyond after this year so I
think they run him into the ground so I
think his usage you'll be off the charts
I'm a little nervous about some
regression from Todd Gurley again I have
it too but over the last five over the
last ten years have been five running
backs that have scored 19 touchdowns in
a season the for one of them's Todd
Gurley I will see what he does this year
four of the previous five have scored
eight or less the following year which
of the last year's fantasy darlings in
chimera a four net and Kareem hunt do
you think actually has another one of
those years I think they all do all if I
have all three in my top 10 so I mean
chimera is a special player in terms of
like no player had more big plays per
touch what a holiday Marin run hitter
you we had remarkable he and markable
you know he's got the first time every
damn touches he's unbelievable player I
mean they they got rid of Adrian
Peterson because of what they had an
Alvin chimera that's why Peterson
couldn't get on the field in New Orleans
because Sean Payton took a look at what
he had in come here and was just like
yeah that guy's not coming off the field
so and with the first four with Ingram
suspended for the first four games I
think Tamara has a
to wait for it run with a job and then
cream hunt was my last year of my
fantasy writer died last year a cream
hunts a special player I believe in for
net a listen the the Jags just the usage
they get out of for net they improve
their offensive line this year they're
gonna run even more I mean like so I
have all three guys in my top 10 who's
your sleeper who do you like that you
think it's gonna be I know you knew the
quiz right yeah well my fantasy rider
died this year and he's becoming less
with sleeper as we get closer and closer
as darius guys I thought - I know I know
he got the first snap of Redskins
training camp - I am I think they're
ready - with you - should have been a
first-round pick and you know whatever
the rumors swirling about him entering
by the way Washington DC loves this kid
every top every person I've talked to
around the team loves this kid and
people don't realize how run friendly a
Jay Gruden off and says last year if you
took rob Kelley and some IDP remember
the Redskins who were starting on their
offensive line guys off the street I
mean they were so beat up and the whole
offense was a cement iyer team was
injured and yet last year they couldn't
run the ball in still semaj pee Ryan and
Robb Kelly if you combine them in one
player they would have been tied for
third in goal to go rushing attempts
last year so now you get garius darius
guys who in the history of the SEC of
running backside had at least 400
carries in the SEC only Bo Jackson has a
higher yards per carry average from
Darius guys in the SEC he averaged six
point five yards running for LSU with no
quarterback he saw so many eight-man
fronts like this guy is just a beast of
a talent he's a better pass catcher than
he gets credit for I think people are
worried about Chris Thompson look they
want to limit Chris Thompson's role on
the field because of because of his
injury history so guys is gonna catch
the ball more than more than people
realize I love geison in all formats
when it's time to go for a defense who
do you think who would you take who's
number one who's your never won D when
the judge is my number one defense but I
won't get the jacks because the Jags
will go like seventh or ninth round
somewhere in there told the rams we did
a study the last nine defenses to score
150 fantasy points or more are all
separate teams like we've never had one
repeat the last three years the top
nine fantasy defense season's over the
last nine years we haven't had one
repeat so the odds are against the
Jaguars or the Rams returning the value
that it would take to draft them like in
the seventh or ninth round I'll give you
a deep sleeper
kaylynn balázs rookie running back in
Miami just just a massive human being
but you don't think Kenyon Drake's gonna
get the lion's share there well the
depth chart came out yesterday and had
Frank Gore and Kenyan Drake both listed
as the number one running starting
running backs I don't think they want
Drake to be an every down back he's a
home run hitter if you will but if you
look at his yards per carry over at you
know there weren't that many games last
year we got a ton of carries but if you
look at what he does by quarter in terms
of yards per carry he's much better in
the first quarter than he is in the
fourth quarter it goes down by quarter
so just I think if Miami's looking at
that they're like hey here's a guy
that's a home run hitter but let's let's
limit his touches and they bring in
Frank Gore I just think there's a chance
the balázs who's basically being
undrafted who's just a big guy who
caught some I think he was misused at
Arizona State but
balázs was a big guy who's a who's a
who's a pretty good pass catcher for a
big guy could carve out a fantasy
relevant role on that team could be
their goal line back and the running
back position I mean we just named what
15 we didn't even talk about McCaffrey
Hulot McCaffrey this here okay I do too
or or sake one sake once again monster I
guess that's the last thing for you
where do you run five running back five
you take your my first-round pick okay I
take him ahead of I have him ahead of
chimera and hunt yeah Wow well look two
things number one is a pat Shermer
offense is very fantasy friendly over a
hundred targets two running backs last
year in Minnesota when he was at
Minnesota and Philadelphia is running
backs were top six in the NFL and
redzone rush percentage and and and
rushing percentage as well right so it's
a very fantasy friendly offense
he's a very good pass catcher you think
about you know Beckham and Ingram and
Shepherd going deep right you're just so
many dump offs to say Quan Barkley and
the other thing rich that I think gets
overlooked a lot in fantasy analysis and
I think this is someone you you can talk
to you know with your role with the NFL
is is that the politics of a football
team play into
football teams are like any other
business right there are politics and
involved the Giants need sake Juan
Barkley to work taking him at number two
passing on darn old passing on a
quarterback taking him at number two
overall they are going to do everything
in their power to make sure sake Juan
Barkley has a successful season he may
not but he's going to be given every
single opportunity because they need
sake Juan to work just from an internal
perspective in my opinion and by the way
like I've interviewed to take one I
don't know if you have I could not have
been more in proud of him he's a good
Union he's a just in just in terms of
his work ethic and how he approaches a
season like I came I was a fan of him
and then I met him and a bigger fan like
there's a very impressed and then
because we have we have run out of time
I mean there was video of him and Odell
Beckham kicking the football like a
soccer ball a hacky sack and initially
cuz I did not know what number he was he
was yet say Quan I thought for a second
my first thought was who's that
defensive lineman kicking the ball
around with Odell just saying the bottom
half of his body he's gonna be making
business decisions created all and then
leading over people you know and in the
Dalvin cook role if you will in that
offense great to see you so you've got
on on the 13th of this month you're 29
our marathon ESPN espn2 ESPNU spean plus
is where you can catch the fantasy show
with you sir correct yes every single
day every single day and then the
fantasy focused football podcast ESPN
Fantasy focused football podcast you can
catch it tonight live at the El Rey
theater and then on Twitter at 11:00
a.m. Eastern on Sundays no we're Monday
through Friday we start back up
Wednesdays because we're out here but
can you download it at iTunes or stream
it on the ESPN app wherever you get a
night wherever you get a podcast and any
fantasy focus podcast is there and at
Matthew berry TMR on Twitter great to
see you thanks for coming by here my
pleasure Mike I don't always know Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience